[MUSIC PLAYING]
JAKE WHARTON: I started
using Kotlin to build Android
apps before I joined Google.
Kotlin allows you to express
the same ideas in your app using
less lines of code.
The more you use the
language, the more
you unlock its
power, and the more
fun it becomes to
use as a result.
Google's supporting Kotlin
as another programming
language for Android
because we want
to do what's best
for developers.
Supporting another programming
language is a ton of work,
but we feel it's the right
thing to do for the community.
DAN KIM: My name is Dan Kim.
And I'm an Android programmer
here at base camp in Chicago.
I had been writing Java
for many, many years.
And in February-ish
of 2016 at base camp,
we decided to take a
deeper look at Kotlin.
Kotlin was different.
Kotlin felt like
it was exciting.
It was fun.
It made us much
happier to work with.
When we heard the
announcement at Google I/O
that Kotlin was going to
be a first class language,
we were super excited.
We knew that that meant for us
better support for the tooling.
And everything was going
to get better for Kotlin.
CHRISTINA LEE: First and
foremost, build times,
they were absolutely insane
when we first started using it.
It was to the point
where we decided
to port our entire build system.
It's been really fun to see
how all of those pain points
early on have kind
of dissipated.
And now the build times are
something that we don't even
have to talk about or
argue about with a bunch
of other developers.
One of the things that
we are surprised about
is how easy it is to quantify
Kotlin's benefit to our code
base.
One of the things that
one of my coworkers did
was pull a graph of the
different high priority
issues filed against a feature
as he slowly migrated it
from fully Java to fully Kotlin.
We would get to the status
quo of 0 most months.
And then maybe there were
some abnormal months where
you'd have one serious issue.
And so that graph just
kind of bottomed out--
a much more stable code base.
SCOTT WEBER: There's been
two key improvements.
One is a broader support and
use of Kotlin in the development
community, means
that there is many
more resources,
libraries, tools,
even articles being written,
that help us to learn
more and get better and faster.
Using Kotlin in
Expedia has helped
us to write more succinct
and easier-to-read code.
It's also helped make our
developers a lot happier.
Now that the language
is stabilized,
we're all much happier
using Kotlin for what we do.
It's also helped guide us
into writing better code
and making sure we're
avoiding no pointed problems.
DAN KIM: The one thing
that we can measure
is that the code is certainly
more concise and clear.
And so we're writing
less code overall.
So I would say that
we write somewhere
between 15% to 25%
less code overall
than we would with Java.
The biggest thing
is that it's made
us really happy to work with.
It's really fun, and
interesting, and exciting,
to work with it.
And it's just not
something we've ever
felt with other languages.
And I've certainly never felt
that with another language.
JAKE WHARTON: It's
exciting to see
how quickly the
developer community has
been adopting Kotlin.
We're just starting to realize
its full potential on Android.
We look forward to continuing
to work with both JetBrains
and UOFF to realize its
full potential on Android.
[MUSIC PLAYING]